and making his 25th start is the
left-hander shamani and kuipe you talked
about it there's just no other way
around it it has been a bit of a bumpy
road here for the big lefty the last few
turns last time out against texas five
innings seven earned runs and really was
bit by the long ball
a little pop-up to shallow right
brown waits and brown's got it
and here's brandon bellowed is batting
237.
high in the air
medium deep left field cannon gets back
there and he's got it so belt is retired
mania has a three up three down inning
bottom of the first coming up a set to
face kevin gausman
let's take a look at kevin gossman
making that 25th start this year great
numbers
starting to right the ship a little bit
but when you see his stuff it's
always going to be based off that splint
finger he's already trying to break in
that slider
tap slowly toward third flores has it
his throw across is wide pass belt
bounces off the side wall canis gonna go
to second and he's gonna try for third
and ken is gonna make it standing out
and here's marta and the giants play the
infield halfway this one is driven
toward the gap in left center field and
it's going to get down cannon will score
marty's going to dig for second and two
batters into the bottom of the first the
a's leave one nothing you know this is
what clubs that are trying to get
themselves to the postseason have to do
that's capitalized on the stakes so
canada reached on the error marte the
double to left center for the rbi olson
bounced out moreland popped out harrison
hit by a pitch and here's seth brown
it's a little flare to left it's gonna
work
two runs are gonna score
and the a's lead three to nothing right
off the end of the bat brown will take
it so here comes sean murphy
got him
with a fastball the damage is three runs
so the giants
no they've got their hands full they
trail three-dumping
becomes the first giant space runner and
it brings up chris bryant kicks throws
swing and there's a shot deep into left
field way back at the wall the leap hits
goal a home run just over the
outstretched glove of canna in left
field a two run homer for chris bryant
and the giants draw back to within a run
three to two oakland solano with 273 a
right-handed hitter
grounds this one diving play harrison he
gets up his throw is high olson got him
on the tag what a play on both ends
saved a run sure did this is all jay hay
could do here you can see him fully
extended ball in the webbing and how
about holy elevate come down put the tag
on solano before he's able to get to the
back and now for the giants they have
runners at first and third and that
flips things to the top and austin
slater is coming up
up the middle
tough hop knocked down the throw to
second base and they got him so tony
campbell he really had to stay with it
and the good news for kemp was that he
had an out at second base to get now
here is andrews
andrews hitting 231
i think it hit his bat it did that's a
three pitch strikeout second strikeout
for guardsman and it brings up cannon
swing ain't gonna miss and another
three-pitch strikeout in a shutdown
inning and the quick inning that gosman
needed he got ruster posey three for his
last 21 standing in
o2 pitch
swings and misses good pitch there by
sean monada
bell to fly ball to left his first time
up
three pitches he is gone so two quick
outs here a couple of strikeouts
two-two pitch is grounded to harrison
harrison's got it
that'll do it so sean monae a much
needed three up three-down inning with a
couple of strikeouts so two outs in the
bottom of the third here's jay
harrison down the left field line and
that's going to work
bounces off the wall it's picked up by
rough they're going to wave olsen home
here comes crawford's throw to the plate
and his late run scores
and that'll make it a 4-2 game so
harrison comes through again chris
bryant with hobart his first time stands
in
and a swing and a miss high fastball
strikeout number three for sean manaya
the giants try to mount the two out
rally with a couple of singles and kurt
casale now comes to the plate and that's
lined into the glove of harrison who
grabs it at the chute tops and that'll
do it so hard hit ball but right at
harrison and the giant strand a pair so
now the bases are loaded this may be
gusman's last guy whatever happens
blocked by casali coming in to score is
murphy he got a good jump he read it
well the ball rolled up the first base
line murphy scores and now it's five to
two three and two here's the pitch it is
swung on and missed he got him to chase
five strikeouts now for gaussman and
gabe kepler's coming out even with that
strikeout he's not going to let kausman
face olson kemp at third canada second
two down
out to left for rough
so the damage could have been worse is
one run and it's 5-2 days bob melvin has
shown so much faith in petite inherits a
bases loaded spot with two out top of
the fifth flores is one for two
right-handed hitter
that one is looped and kept grabs it so
right out the end of the bat florence
just kept chasing that pitch outside and
petite gets the big out and the giants
do not score tommy the stella is gonna
bat for donovan solano is five giants
two one out top of the six
alessandra scoops it up flips to first
two outs
single and that'll bring up austin
slater is slide to right bounce into a
force play and lined out
and that's a swing and a miss by slater
you smear a petite comes up big
again man he just keeps getting big outs
year after year his lineup's been shut
down by the a's brandon belt now stands
in here's a swing by belt in a drive to
right field this one is deep and this
one is gone brandon belt
up over the right field wall
went down against a low pitch to dig it
out and he smoked it his 17th home run
of the year
and the lead for the a's is down to two
five to three oakland still only one out
and darren ruff stands in the a's
bullpen is quiet
ruff
slams one to left
and
out of here
and now it's a one run game well andrew
chapin has finally given up runs as it
ain't one allowed all year before today
and now back to back by the jags for the
second time in the eight innings of the
game where the giants have gotten their
lead off man on base so here is la
stella
stella has got a bloop and that's a base
hit
and crawford had thoughts but he puts on
the breaks so the bloop is in order so
here is kurt cosali the sally to butt
and he bunts it in the air and deacon
grabs it so on the first pitch casali
pops it up right to deep in one out and
now the hitter is austin slater who is
old for four and the runners go and
they're gonna have them picked off
they're gonna run crawford back to
second tag him out and that's the second
out execution by the athletics horrible
execution by the giants
deacon ready throws and it's swung out
and mouse fast fall up and away and the
ass get out of it so a pinch hitter
weighed batting for rough and a pinch
runner yaz running for belt
high and deep to right down the line it
is
out of here
and the giants take the lead what an
at-bat by lamont wade junior kepler once
again pulling the right strings the
giants fans erupted two down but now
starling marche
what
a win
for the giants and if you said that you
saw this one coming i don't believe you
never a doubt